[Musica]
Buon
pomeriggio allora vi chiedo di
immaginarvi nella nella vostra auto
dovete arrivare in una destinazione Che
non conoscete e quindi avviate il
navigatore e quindi Scegliete il
percorso che per voi è più geniale
perciò avete a disposizione una serie di
informazioni vedete per esempio la il
tempo di di percorrenza il costo del del
tragitto e quindi Scegliete in base alle
informazioni che avete il tragitto il
tragitto da fare avviate il vostro
navigatore e quindi cominciate la
marcia poi durante la marcia Chiaramente
sempre in base alle informazioni che
avete decidete se deviare il percorso
questo magari per arrivare nei tempi nei
tempi
prestabiliti Poi immagino che a tutti
voi almeno a me è capitato tantissime
volte andate a finire in strade di
campagna salite ripide strade dissestate
e quindi non è detto che riusciate ad
arrivare a destinazione nei nei tempi
previsti o ci arrivate ma dopo aver
fatto un rally e questo perché Perché la
difficoltà del percorso non è una delle
informazioni che avete a disposizione
per per decidere Ecco io mi occupo
faccio ricerca e insegno su quelli che
sono i sistemi di misurazione della
performance aziendale che sono dei
sistemi di informazioni i navigatori che
imprenditori e manager usano per fissare
gli obiettivi decidere quali azioni
intraprendere e quindi in base ai quali
prendono decisioni
ora capite bene
che è estremamente importante che ci
siano tutte le informazioni importanti
per decidere all'interno di questi
sistemi di misurazione della performance
e questo perché Perché all'interno delle
delle imprese ciò che viene misurato
viene
gestito perché questo perché ciò che
viene misurato salta All'attenzione dei
Manager su quello focalizzano
l'attenzione e quindi quelli diventano
poi i criteri con i quali vanno a
prendere decisioni Quindi se manca
un'informazione importante come nel caso
precedente la difficoltà del percorso si
rischia che quel criterio non entri
all'interno all'interno delle scelte
e non è così scontato non lo è per
niente che i sistemi di misurazione
della performance aziendale inglobo
tutte le informazioni che sono
importanti per decidere vi porto con me
nel mio ultimo progetto di ricerca è un
progetto di ricerca bellissimo ed è un
progetto che sto conducendo con alcuni
colleghi di altre aree che si occupa di
raccolta di plastiche in mare e
riutilizzo di Queste plastiche
chiaramente il mio gruppo di ricerca Dio
ci occupiamo della parte economica e
quindi di definire un modello di
valutazione che consente alle imprese di
capire se conviene loro acquistare un
impianto con una nuova tecnologia che
consente di trasformare le plastiche non
riciclabili in questo caso raccolte in
mare ma potrebbero essere plastiche non
riciclabili tukur in energia elettrica
l'alternativa per un'impresa è portare
questa plastica in
discarica allora chi chi ci può aiutare
chi ci ha aiutato a costruire questo
modello di valutazione Allora Chiunque
abbia fatto ragioneria ha sentito
parlare del paciolo di Fran luuca
Pacioli che nella seconda metà del 1400
inizio 1500 ha inventato la partita
doppia quindi è il padre della
ragioneria Che cosa vuol dire questo
vuol dire che le informazioni di natura
economica ricavi costi profitti hanno
radici profondissime e se voi ci pensate
sono i criteri con cui comunemente noi
definiamo lo stato di salute delle
imprese e chiaramente con cui le imprese
prendono decisioni e a me c'è qualcosa
che ha sempre affascinato di queste di
queste misure il fatto che siano delle
misure chiare
incontrovertibili tra di loro ci sono
relazioni matematiche tu sai che se
Riduci i costi aumenta il profitto se
aumenti i costi invece si riduce si
riduce il profitto e quindi chiaramente
quando vengono utilizzate danno
indicazioni chiare a chi le utilizza
eh passiamo al nostro al nostro progetto
e Certo è che se noi mettiamo a
confronto quelli che sono i costi che
un'impresa deve sostenere per acquisire
l'impianto farlo funzionare nel tempo
manuten anche al netto dei benefici che
si otterrebbero per esempio dalla
produzione di energia di questa plastica
e quindi Risparmio di costi in energia
oppure magari l'energia la potrei
vendere Quindi anche al netto di quelli
sono superiori rispetto a quanto
costerebbe ad un'impresa portare la
plastica in
discarica Allora quello che noi ci
dobbiamo chiedere è se sul piatto
abbiamo messo tutte le informazioni che
sono importanti per
decidere in realtà non ce le abbiamo
messe tutte se ci pensiamo Perché Perché
i benefici dell'acquisizione di questo
impianto sono sono tanti sono per
esempio il fatto che riduciamo
l'inquinamento nell'ambiente ma non solo
aumenta la reputazione di un'impresa che
utilizza questo tipo di tecnologia
Perché Perché migliora la relazione con
la comunità pensate per tutti noi quanto
è importante avere vicino delle imprese
che non inquinino o che si Curino del
nostro ambiente di più vado avanti si
aprono nuovi segmenti di mercato perché
perché ci sono consumatori che sono
sempre più attenti ai comportamenti
Green delle imprese e quindi si possono
avere nuovi consumatori di più ancora
può migliorare la relazione con i
dipendenti l'attrazione dei nuovi
talenti che adesso dei giovani che è
importantissima per le nostre imprese un
altro aspetto si riduce quello che è un
fenomeno che adesso si sta vedendo
tantissimo nelle nostre organizzazione
ossia il conscious quitting cioè le
dimissioni volontarie quando un'impresa
non corrisponde al tuo sistema valoriale
quindi i vantaggi sono tanti C'è però un
problema Possiamo misurarli
economicamente possiamo misurare
economicamente il miglioramento della
reputazione di un'impresa o il
miglioramento dell'attrazione dei nuovi
talenti e purtroppo no E quindi quello
che si rischiamo che si verifichi è
questo ossia che non tutto ciò che viene
contato conta e non tutto ciò che conta
viene contato Questa è una frase che si
dice che Einstein avesse in nella parete
del suo del suo studio e quindi questo
che cosa vuol dire che se noi non li
possiamo contare non li possiamo fare
emergere questi criteri non entrano
nelle nostre scelte decisionali E allora
Permettetemi di scomodare un altro pezzo
da 90 prima ho scomodato la testa adesso
scomodo scomodo il cuore rischiamo che
ciò che è essenziale resti invisibili e
in
effetti da studi effettuati ma anche da
ricerca empiriche è proprio emerso che
alla radice del valore delle imprese ci
siano proprio quelle che si chiamano le
risorse invisibili le risorse
intangibili quelle che non hanno
consistenza fisica competenze dei
dipendenti conoscenze know-how pensate a
un modello organizzativo efficace che
faccia lavorare bene le persone e
trasferisca bene le conoscenze oppure
pensiamo alle relazioni relazioni con
clienti e fornitori ma non solo
l'aspetto economico che conta tantissimo
ma le relazioni di fiducia le relazioni
di Cooperazione pensiamo alle relazioni
di rispetto dell'ambiente pensiamo alle
relazioni con le comunità Ecco tutti
questi aspetti sono intangibili e quindi
quello che è importante è che
all'interno dei sistemi di misurazione
delle performance queste risorse possano
entrare e in effetti una misurazione è
possibile solo che non è una misurazione
di natura economica per esempio la
reputazione la possiamo misurare la
possiamo misurare tramite dei
questionari noi proprio ieri abbiamo
fatto tutta una serie di questionari
alla cittadinanza Per capire proprio
quanto migliorasse la reputazione di
un'impresa e la propensione quindi a
rivolgersi a quell'impresa se un
cittadino sa che quell'impresa utilizza
delle tecnologie Green le competenze
possono essere misurate differenziate e
poi misurate tramite delle scale di
valori un modello organizzativo efficace
lo possiamo misurare per esempio tramite
il numero di giorni che intercorre tra
la nascita di un'idea e il momento in
cui diviene un un prodotto finito e
quindi sostanzialmente Io mi sono sempre
occupata di questo ossia di cercare di
rendere visibile l'invisibile e di farlo
tramite appunto dei dei sistemi di
misurazione della performance far
entrare queste queste risorse queste
misure all'interno dei sistemi di
misurazione della performance e quindi
nel tempo ho sviluppato Ovviamente
insieme a colleghi una serie di modelli
Non ultimo il sistema di valutazione di
quel famoso impianto di cui di cui
parlavamo prima in cui sono entrate
queste queste nuove variabili però mi
sono anche occupata di vedere
qualcos'altro ossia di vedere che cosa
succede nelle organizzazioni quando
introduciamo questi sistemi di
misurazione perché perché sono misure
nuove non è che risalgono a fine 1400
inizio 1500 e
quindi ho cercato di vedere che cosa
accade Allora innanzitutto si introduce
incertezza incertezza nelle scelte
decisionali Perché Eh perché se ci sono
studi che supportano il fatto che
aumentando le competenze dei dipendenti
poi questo si rifletterà in maniera
positiva da un punto di vista economico
in realtà Quanto e quando dipende dalla
singola
organizzazione non solo c'è un altro
aspetto anche fondamentale ossia che
l'introduzione di queste misure è
un'azione di Change Management Che cosa
vuol dire vuol dire che noi introduciamo
nuove informazioni introduciamo nuovi
criteri introduciamo nuovi e guardate
che non è che introduciamo dei Semplici
numeri perché noi introduciamo dei
numeri che parlano di persone dei numeri
che parlano di relazioni tra persone di
relazioni tra gruppi di competenze e
quindi che cosa succede che per andare a
sviluppare questi sistemi di misurazione
noi entriamo nella pancia delle
organizzazioni andiamo a toccare le
attività che svolgono le persone e
quindi a differenza di quelle economiche
noi creiamo e generiamo delle reazioni
generiamo anche delle emozioni e tante
volte queste misure vengono accettate e
tante volte invece vengono rifiutate
rifiutate vuol dire non utilizzate
e per esempio in uno dei primissimi
progetti di ricerca che ho svolto
abbiamo misurato il benessere lavorativo
come lo abbiamo misurato abbiamo cercato
di vedere l'efficacia del sistema di
diffusione delle informazioni che
servono ai dipendenti per lavorare
nell'organizzazione
l'impresa aveva da poco fatto un nuovo
investimento in software proprio per la
diffusione delle delle conoscenze in
database abbiamo messo un sistema di
misure abbiamo visto che effettivamente
le conoscenze venivano immesse in questi
sistemi ma i dipendenti non le
utilizzavano perché non le utilizzavano
perché poi a fronte della misura ci sono
poi delle riflessioni non le usavano
perché le modalità di apprendimento di
questa organizzazione dei dipendenti
erano di tipo verbale e quindi quello
era una modalità completamente distante
dalle loro dai loro modi di di
apprendere quindi l'impresa ha fatto una
scelta forte ha accettato queste
informazioni ha lasciato da parte questo
investimento e ha potenziato questo tipo
d'apprendimento ad esempio investendo in
comunità di
pratica oppure per esempio pensiamo alla
misurazione della efficacia della
Formazione Anche questo è un altro
progetto che ho avuto in un'altra
impresa abbiamo abamo cercato di
misurarne l'efficacia però non son con
le solite ore di formazione o costo
della Formazione ma andando a vedere
quanto aumentano le competenze dei
dipendenti quando viene fatta formazione
e che cosa succede succede che io mi
ricordo discussioni interminabili con il
responsabile risorse umane Perché Perché
chiaramente il risultato di questa
misurazione non dipendeva solamente
Dalla scelta dell'attività formativa che
aveva scelto ma dipendevano anche dalla
possibilità del dipendente di scaricarla
a terra nel suo lavoro e dell'impresa di
metterlo nelle condizioni di poter
svolgere adeguatamente la sua attività e
quindi questo che cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che queste misure sono soggettive
non sono oggettive non ci sono quelle
relazioni incontrovertibili che dicevamo
precedentemente e a cui siamo a cui
siamo abituati la cosa più bella però è
questa cioè sono le discussioni le
riflessioni che alimentano queste
informazioni perché questo perché fanno
sorgere nuove consapevolezze e noi
sappiamo che facendo nascere nuove
consapevolezze quindi questa è una
condizione necessaria anche se non
sufficiente però almeno è necessaria poi
per portare un cambiamento E allora se
noi ci pensiamo quando noi andiamo a
misurare il capitale umano quando noi
misuriamo le conoscenze le competenze
dei dipendenti quando misuriamo il
benessere lavorativo noi Samo producendo
umanità nei sistemi di
misurazione quando noi andiamo a
misurare le relazioni la cura delle
relazioni la cura delle relazioni con i
miei clienti nella direzione che dicevo
prima no di fiducia di Cooperazione le
relazioni con l'ambiente con le
strutture formative con la comunità Noi
andiamo ad introdurre la cura e quindi
la gentilezza all'interno dei sistemi di
misurazione e quindi i sistemi di
misurazione che poi sembrano così aridi
così distaccati così matematici così
rigidi eh in realtà possono accogliere
delle dimensioni che sono appunto quello
della dell'umanità e della gentilezza
però ci dobbiamo ricordare una cosa che
le misure che noi stiamo
introducendo non sono quelle classiche e
sono un po' come le persone perché
possono essere misure forti convincenti
misure fragili criticabili attaccabili
per perché
soggettive possono far stare nella le
persone nella loro zona di comfort
oppure possono sfidarle e quindi
provocano emozioni reazioni però aprono
tante possibilità con le loro con le
discussioni che poi che poi sollecitano
aprono proprio la possibilità di creare
un futuro che sia un futuro inclusivo
cioè un futuro inclusivo di tanti valori
all'interno dell'impresa non solo quello
economico e un futuro in cui
tutti vedono percepiscono e sono
consapevoli della propria responsabilità
nella creazione di quel di quel
futuro Quindi diciamo che per per
concludere Io credo veramente che i
sistemi di misurazione della performance
possano essere dei veicoli di
trasferimento di valori e di cultura e
di trasferimento proprio anche
di e di izione di dimensioni come
l'umanità e la gentilezza che sembrano
così distanti
[Musica]
Grazie